[Music]
of insiders America First Love the
flow
ior
[Music]
friends still
quiet it's
science
[Music]
[Applause]
I woke up in my head
this I woke
up I woke up in my
head I woke up I'm not a boob
guy
[Music]
guys I'm
gay thees
makeone from
[Music]
the I think you've got a confession to
make you're fake news you are fake news
what Trump was making America
great where were
you when you try to
resist and me
you yeah Trump is getting the best the
best the best the best of
best the best the best
you least four years we're just to sneak
bre
you can I get your attention for some
breaking
news the are already
TI prepare to
lose your nursing home call
down you got you you
blue think you can take for more
years of this of
VI cuz Trump is getting the best the
best the best the best of
you get the best the best the best the
best of
you Reis unemployment rates it's real
the markets heal your rush you must
confess your trp is getting the best the
best the best the best of
you
[Music]
w
wow
wow now it's time for confession my
friends you're fake news
[Music]
are you ready to lose
again when Biden
poops you can try to
resist but you will
lose my terms are short of like Twix by
friends they
come cuz Trump is getting the best the
best the best the best of you
yeah I keep getting the best the best
the best the best of
you the best best
best
[Music]
you remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight at lwith
credit.com mug club
today
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I
know
change I
got
[Music]
not everything's a laughing matter so
before we
get before we get to anything today um I
need to update you we told you this on
Friday um and by the way uh because this
may not be on YouTube if at some point
right now during this program you see
this that means head on over to rumble
it's relevant to the story before we get
to everything else uh thanks to M Club
you know last Tuesday we revealed um how
an executive at black rock may have had
her email connected to a child
exploitation site definitely this email
was connected um and we had a response
from those lawyers we followed up on
that but for a very brief recap here you
go a website designed for the explicit
purpose of sexually exploiting children
there are fewer greater on Earth than
the abuse and exploitation of innocent
children what you're about to see here
is nothing short of truly disturbing you
can never unknow but we think you need
to know because it's the
truth now after that clip ran we did
receive a letter from that individual's
lawyer and we also recapped that uh and
since then that lawyer's page has been
uh put into prce private and the woman's
LinkedIn as well so there have been some
developments this is the rape. suu story
so last Thursday and I mentioned this on
Instagram Black Rock actually sent a
very Stern demand to rumble um as well
as our web hosting site and its vendors
to take down the video completely so to
recap this mug undercover received a tip
regarding a hacked database of a child
exploitation site our team attempted to
connect the email address from the
database to True names and one user
hero1 121 mail.com consistently pointed
to Abigail gold Galler we asked giler if
she owned hero1 121 mail.com we were
promptly contacted by the attorney who
said that that email was not associated
with it you can go back and see the
entire Saga we have covered it yeah we
have been accurate
um as best as we can be of course and uh
you know sometimes people uh make
mistakes we have not so now they have
requested to rumble to have this removed
and gone after all of our vendors to try
and remove well I guess undo your
support and ensure that um you know we
cannot make a living however we always
have to take ownership over our mistakes
and if there is a mistake that we've
made obviously legally there are
ramifications so our official response
today to Black Rock is go fornicate
[Music]
yourself and if you don't like it talk
to talk to Chris pavlowsky CEO of Rumble
I'm sure he'll get right on that good
luck all right coming after our vendors
on our for for our web Serv you jerks
eat a bag of rice and figuratively now
figuratively we wouldn't actually tell
you to do that so today we will be
talking about uh a lot to get to ilon
Omar is Somalia first it's a new thing
it's a new Wing oh there at least
there's one person that's they control
One bank it's really more of a credit
union oh boy and uh there's Taylor Swift
AI uh pornography that's making the
rounds which actually is is pretty
interesting to get into as far as what
this means for society legally um what
the ramifications are who's accountable
and then actually in Gerald knows things
there was a drone strike that has killed
American soldiers in Jordan and people
think that something might pop off yeah
with Iran here relatively soon and
everyone here is pretty damn sick today
so my question of the day is what do you
think should be done to regulate AI
going forward especially as
conservatives who don't really like the
term regulation you hear it and you
break out in hives and U you know into
antic shock number two Captain Morgan
with SARS how you I'm I'm doing better
than I was Friday yeah I know it was it
was a bit rough I blame you mostly um I
absolutely zero yes yes I was patient
zero and it's not even but I'm telling
you the clear nasal spray and the xylol
stuff and like I was still doing shows I
felt like crap yeah you know absolutely
but you sound uh you are you feeling
better now though no you have a lot to
look forward to oh good he sounds very
stuffy like he's not using clear does
he's no he's not using clear
everything's good my voice jald doesn't
do anything like he's before you get
into C and flu like Gerald just like oh
wait uh you know fruit is good for me
like he doesn't I don't know that it is
he's still stuck on just like no don't
eat a hogi every day and when you hear
this oh he he's here now he's a
permanent fixture we love him we thank
him for his service and he's going to be
at uh Osage or osagi I don't know Casino
in uh Panka City Oklahoma could be Pon I
have no idea February 12th the point is
he's going to be in Oklahoma February
12th and you can follow him on all the
profiles Josh 17th that doesn't even
look like a two February 17th February
17th I didn't I said 12th did I
twice thank you for your service I
apologize for the sick man I wasn't
going to bring it up personally I was
going to let you just have it February
17th thank you for calling me on it's
because by the way I'm not sick I just
sound like this cuz I was doing coke
with Gerald all weekend yes you it sound
like Little Wayne in an interview it's
called Columbian gold struggling to get
your words out but thank you for your
service appreciate it yeah so uh all
right okay let's move on ilon Omar to be
clear this is something that is uh
disconcerting first off a more dis
concern you know ilon Omar married
banged her brother so here you go
there's the marriage certificate and
please Wherever You Are YouTube rum put
in the comment section ilon Omar married
her brother or ilon Omar banged her
brother we want that written as many
times as possible for the algorithm
because even Snopes said all right but
they just didn't want to investigate
post it on X right now too it happened
it's real this is that person it was a
consummation there yes exactly fully
consummated and she sounds like
Rafiki so does she it's true
Hezbollah Isis
no so this woman who claims to represent
you like treason used to be a remember
when treason was a thing yeah people who
claim to represent you but then actually
are basically acting on behalf of a
foreign power I don't know at what point
you say hey the founders wouldn't even
had a page for this um so this
woman um this incestuous uh woman with a
ticking pants suit she was speaking to a
crowd of Somali and she said that
expanding Somali territory is her
priority as an incestuous
congresswoman
[Laughter]
only do what Somalians in the US tell
them
to a might have
to
[Applause]
sleep in Comfort with your brother
knowing that I am here to protect the
Somali interest in the United States she
talks about the Somali is you know a
proud PE
why what are you proud
of like okay Somalian should be proud of
a lot name one
the one thing they're known for they're
not even good at the pirating they're
not even good at bad
pirates I don't know anything else
they're known for I shouldn't be able to
take out all of your pirates with a
water cannon you're you're on the ocean
like oh there was a
starfish rug burn so she
also she used the opportunity by the way
to plug her new documentary um following
her journey to reunite with her
ex-husband oh my gosh there you go
people on audio it's a video show good
news she found him again yes she did in
her bed she did he didn't get far yeah
he was imprisoned then you know he was a
specialist in the metalogical Arts now
here's the thing and this is like she's
a symptom and it's a hilarious and gross
symptom of a greater problem is you have
a lot of Representatives who uh are not
actual Representatives can we get rid of
the term public servant it's one thing
that a lot of people actually
appreciated about Nixon after the
stories if he got a couple of drinks in
Nixon he basically said the guy who took
me out were the same guys who took
Kennedy out you know the three-letter
agencies they didn't want him but he
said I don't want to do that because I
still want people to think that it's
Noble to go into public service why it's
not most of these people are corrupt
they are not serving you they go in poor
and they leave Rich because of benefits
and protections that you never will be
afforded yourself now it's just taken to
the extreme when one is a um you know
Somalian um brother Banger so are they
hiring cuz I fit all those boxes you're
not Somalian Jos your brother belongs to
me now you don't know that so here's the
thing all congressmen and women and Z's
and Pirates take this oath when being
sworn in I do solemnly swear that I will
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic that I will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that I take this obligation freely
without any any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion and that I will well
and Faithfully discharge the duties of
the office on which I am about to enter
so help me God so here's the thing by
becoming a congressman or rep you cannot
act as an agent for another
government now Senator Bob Menendez he
may be the first legislator like to
actually try and deliberately act as a
foreign agent in this case you know
Egypt but if you're doing um this is the
less extreme example saying this is our
priority I am here to serve the interest
of Somalia well then you shouldn't be
here go to Somalia bet you
won't ask me how I know that but one of
the things that I think tip people off
to this speech to begin with was she
said first I'm a Somalian second I'm a
Muslim American not on the list right
not the list that's what she was saying
to this audience and I understand when
you're speaking to an audience you want
to identify with the audience you want
to make sure that they understand that
their voices will be heard that's fine
and say hey I'm I'm I'm your
representative I'm going to make sure
that the things that matter to us here
not Kenya taking our I could care less
if Kenya wants to take over some of your
fishing Waters what are they going to
Pirate better than talking about
Ethiopia and Kenya and Ethiopia both of
them were encroaching on there and I'm
like yes me five people on the continent
of America or North America that care I
don't I don't know of anybody who does
I'm sorry it's just not one of our
geopolitical issues I care how many pool
cues you break over each other's heads
yeah but in in pandering to your
audience you can't say I'm Somalian
first I'm Muslim second and Americans
know we on the list because America is
the one that gave you the voice
otherwise you would just be one more
person in that godforsaken place yeah
sorry I and I care about the people that
are there I care about human suffering
but you can't come here and look at the
opportunity you've been given and and
get to a station in life where you have
this voice now and go I don't like this
can be extrapolated anything Ukraine we
extrapolate to foreign aid to count like
look it's not I'm sorry it's not our job
hey you know what how about this hey hey
Somalia we could lose a we could use a
hand send it don't send an actual hand
send they have plenty of send send
whatever currency you use there in that
God forsaken hey hey you know Ethiopia
come help us
out why why is it always incumbent upon
us and then why do people in our
government de said that they want to act
in the interest of other countries who
by the way have benefited the benefited
the world in no significant way let's
just be clear not all cultures are equ
it's 2024 in Somalia too yeah wasn't she
censored censured or is that somebody
else uh was it her or
she she's coming they're all terrorists
they're coming soon she won't to do
anything and to be fair we did cut that
clip off early she did say uh Somalian
firstam second uh wife third sister
fourth well she said wife SL sister yeah
her priorities is a little messed up
there sister wife she had a greater than
symbol scratched out and then equal yeah
equal to and by the way I think we have
a CNN Headline that two Navy Seals
identified after being killed off the
coast of
Somalia these are not this is January
22nd I think not not very long ago yeah
right so it's like listen guys I'm sorry
but you can't go and give speeches like
that you can't go and give a speech that
says something happened on 911 some
people did some things you know this is
just it's the pattern that I hate well
you see it with all these repr they all
want to act as though they are noble oh
I'm a public servant no you're not now
most of you are not public servants
let's be clear about that and by the way
comment below do you have a great local
representative who you feel actually
serves you I can think of a couple I
think ran Paul is one of those guys
because he genuinely doesn't care like
he's willing to make himself imminently
unlikable just by standing on principle
and serving his uh Representatives he
does it well most people do not if you
have a portfolio that outpaces the
market and the average American by I
don't know 20 times you're probably not
a public servant so that's the main
issue and of course Anon Omar banged her
brother uh you can still
repeatedly I wish I love anything as
much as that woman loves banging
Brothers brother brother well it's the
one we know about true it's the one who
put a ring on it she married her
favorite brother you know she had she
took serious he it's the one brother who
took her seriously enough yeah to marry
her gross done the time yeah the other
brother's like pretty women so yeah
exactly she banged the Middle Brother
she said there's nothing here and moved
on and he said how wo it was a goldilux
thing yeah that's exactly what it a new
this brother is just
right someone's been sleeping in my bed
oh boy both of us all
right look at me yes look at me I am the
wife
now these are your ovaries now
this baby maker belongs to me I don't
know how to handle this but you know
what it's not any worse than the royal
family who developed Blue Blood because
of all the iness
hey the point is not all culturs are
equal and you can still join mug Club as
you see what's happening with black rock
uh and I'm sure there's more coming down
the pike um you can join mug Club you
know it's $89 annually you get this
wonderful hand etched mug you get all
the other programs right you get the
Hodge twins you get Nick depal every day
you get Alex Jones on Friday you get
more content that's coming down uh the
pike you get our show on Friday or you
can go mug list $9 a month where you can
try it out but you don't get the mug
okay it's time to go to Taylor Swift do
we have to oh shut up I don't like
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift uh AI
pornography controversy because I think
there's no one likes Taylor Swift well a
lot of people lot of people like no one
in this room is a huge is a Swifty is a
Swifty I'm going to shake that off are
you shake that off I'm going to shake
that comment off now and I don't have
any other references any other is there
bad blood don't make me spill spill tear
my guitar no
that's a deep cut there hey you and I
are Never Ever Ever Getting Back
Together come on you sound like a gay
but this is our
song our song's a sound of screen door
Stephen shut
okay you know what the worst part is
about this the reason this goes back and
forth is because I'm upset yes CU he's a
married man but he belongs with me
entertainment
[Music]
minute
all right so uh last week and this this
does bring up some interesting and I'm
curious to hear from you it does bring
up some interesting questions and
certainly legislatively where you do
have to balance Freedom uh with problems
that are presented in the new world that
infringe upon individual freedoms so
there was AI generated pornography uh of
Taylor Swift that flooded social media
and uh that of course has sort of
spurred a longer conversation about AI
tonight the White House expressing alarm
after explicit so-called deep fakes of
Superstar Taylor Swift flooded social
media the administration now calling out
platforms for lack enforcement against
artificial intelligence one of the fake
images of Swift reportedly shared over
47 million times on X in what advocacy
groups say is a form of sexual abuse I
love it sound the alarm like it's like
it's a Paul Riv with a raging
erection the new swifties are coming
poros are coming the POR the perverts
are coming actually I would appreciate
an alarm that would tell me the perverts
are coming it would yeah it would kind
of I mean I don't really necessarily
know that someone's perverted if they
want to see Taylor Swift naked she's in
her 30s you know I'm saying but it's but
it's wrong okay let me let me before I
get into trouble so
Twitter Twitter suspended all searches
for Taylor Swift and according to a post
by ex uh safety they said posting
non-consensual nudity uh images is
strictly prohibited on X and we have a
zero tolerance policy towards such
content our teams are actively removing
all identified images and taking
appropriate action against the accounts
responsible for posting them we actually
have an exclusive picture of said Tech
Team live here hard at
work yeah well well that almost seems
like they need to have a supervising
manager they said we're closely
monitoring the situation to ensure that
any further violations are immediately
addressed and the content is removed or
remove or committed to maintaining a
safe and respectful environment for all
users because when I think X I think
respectful um yeah definitely a place
and even more egregious by the way in
the eyes of her fans rather than the AR
porn are the photos of her on January
6th ow come on
now that looks real she was there I we
have to be peaceful I knew you were in
trouble when you walked in
now here's the thing with AI porn uh
pornography first off we you know agree
that porn is bad for your your soul
pornography okay I'm anti-porn doesn't
mean that I don't like looking at naked
ladies this is the thing everyone will
try and say oh you're okay sure fine
every single man is a hypocrite because
we've all looked at naked ladies and we
like looking at more naked ladies it's
like you ladies with dresses or shoes we
like looking at as many as possible
that's how we're hardwired it doesn't
mean that it's not wrong now when we get
to deep fake artificial intelligence
porn there is no federal law Banning it
on the books and only 10 states they
have any type of of law addressing it
and her home state of Tennessee does not
have those so this does bring up some
interesting questions actually she's on
CNN right now Karen jeampier where um
she looks even more weird when she's not
at the podium because she like her she
owns no neck
so Saturday though we
have Karen
J uh not look like a messed up carbon
Electro she does she looks like she
might have a brother marriage
certificate somewhere down
here um Saturday she addressed the
controversy uh specifically we are
alarmed by uh the reports of the of the
circulation of images that you just laid
out false images to be more exact and it
is
alarming do you like using the word
alarming I don't think she cares she
does not care one like white
get what she asked for she's also a
lesbian I'm sure she doesn't care at all
yeah just connect she's alarmed yeah
she's alarmed yeah fine she's alarmed
she's like do all bodies look like that
Taylor Swift's body doesn't look like
that no Taylor Swift is albino she has
no first time she saw curves on herself
so here's the thing um and I get it
where people you know and this also
happened with the PornHub situation
where they were saying hey you need to
now verify your age uh and I think that
you should need to verify your age for
pornography right problem is you also
now have a major database where your
privacy is being infringed it was a
different thing if you had to show ID to
go buy for example a Playboy in the
store so this does come with some
complications and who is liable this is
how do we want to move forward here as a
society uh you can comment below what
you think should be done some people are
trying to say just see like a Democrat s
up and I have no idea what there's a
bunch of conspiracy theories no I don't
think so allegedly she could who who's
responsible you have an AI generator
let's say someone creates this through
an AI generator um the person or is it
the AI machine where I think that's
probably the one that would have to be
the most liable where they would have to
program into it hey we're not going to
Ally AI pornography to be created with
our AI software because if they allow
for that to be done and then it gets
distributed the other component is
people are profiting off of it right
yeah right that's very different from
just a Photoshop that's kind of funny
it's a meme if a website is getting
millions and millions of people watching
this and making millions of dollars then
someone at some point is responsible if
it falls under the idea of you know
fraud defamation yeah and it just seems
like the law really hasn't caught up
with this right now we we talked about
it before the show we were saying like
you know when Photoshop came out you now
have the ability to crudely put
somebody's head or face over a body and
be like hahaa right but you could kind
of see that that's obviously not that
person and so there wasn't any real
understanding that hey this this this
could technically possibly even be real
now you've gotten we've just gotten
better at it we got better technology
better capabilities but I don't think
you go to taking away freedom of speech
right and this is where you don't want
to infringe on this you do go to well
what are the laws yeah I you can't for
example if you want to put like you know
Joe Biden doing a line of coke with like
you know underage prostitutes or
something like that you can't do that
right that's against the law right you
can't you can't malign
hunter say hunter I say hunter that's a
gray area there's a reason I didn't say
hunter um but you can't do that with Joe
Biden so there are laws that we can just
now start to understand how to apply to
these situations but like you said it
does go back to the AI generation and
then it goes to the sites that hosted if
something's on a site that does break
the law which we've always stood for and
said look if you have something on a
site that breaks the law they can ask
for it to be taken down it should be
taken down that's fine that's what
should happen here and then the person
has the recourse of suing and saying hey
you profited off of my name image or
likeness right yeah the laws are pretty
clear it's like is it is it parody
satire this clearly is not meant to look
like that so people are fooled and then
are they profiting off of it those
things typically are taken into account
whether it's copyright whether it's
false use of image uh whether it's
defamatory um so I it's a tough one but
we are in an era too where this we've
talked about this is what we did this
Clean Slate campaign where it's just
aggregation people don't want to create
anything now they just want to aggregate
you have scripts for crying out loud in
Hollywood they're using AI for huge
bulks of these scripts uh you're saying
this for a lot that's why things feel
less creative that's why you go on in
stagram and it's a scroll and it's a
clip and a clip and a clip and a clip a
clip of a standup comedian on some
profile who doesn't even know who that
person is yeah it's saw one with George
Carlin and didn't even attribute it to
George Carlin it was like his name
didn't even exist it's like a whole
special or something wasn't it yeah yeah
that was a big uh case that actually
existed this idea of a re-appropriating
Content you're not you're not
transforming it used to be the law and
now you've added hey yeah I get it I'd
be super pissed if I was Taylor Swift
you know you I don't I'm not a fan but
she's not a porno actress you know she's
not banging her brother like Elon Omar
so you know it's one of those things
where you go hey well hold on a second
that's not me that that's something that
her kids if she you know ever ends up uh
wanting to be a mother which you know
probably when she's in her 40s and she
realizes that her window has closed and
it's too late ouch she she'll be upset
about it so and this is why are people
only noticing this now too like this is
a problem with culture and this is one
thing I also want to clarify too like
for example as a Christian conservative
I was always saying and we were always
saying like you know what rock bands
people you know people out there some of
the black pill red pill Community saying
bang a bunch of chicks I think that's
bad I think it's bad for your soul right
feels good sex Feels Good Naked Ladies
okay great but it's bad for your soul
and you lose a piece of it if that's the
way that you live I believe that
pursuing virtue for the sake of virtue
is more rewarding than temporary
Pleasures okay that being said I also
have to defend mcjagger and David Bowie
and Tommy Lee when you have people
coming out 30 40 years later saying that
they felt exploited it's like you showed
up for an orgy at a motly crew concert
in
1987 this can't just be group this can't
just be a 401k for groupies so having
said orgy bad morally for you personally
legally this is not a violation of
consent and it's crazy now that conser
do you guys feel this way that
conservative Christians are the one
going well hold a second we said this is
bad for you personally but we're also
not saying that it should be illegal and
these people deserve protections and the
left that was en entirely prosexual
Liberation birth control women go out
and be that's how you'll be just
as powerful as men are now saying no no
no we're going to we're going to
disempower you by saying that you can't
even take accountability for your
proactive consent you can retroactively
pull it back the sexual Revolution now
makes no sense yeah and and they they're
the ones that have come up with these
consent apps essentially in the like in
cities like New York where it's like yes
can you know imagine being in the middle
of you know making out with somebody and
you're like hey do you mind signing this
uh form really quickly yeah it says how
far we oh you're only going to let me go
that far yeah yeah by the way there I
don't know if you know this it is not it
is not accepted uh as legally
representative in Somalia consent yeah
yeah no they just SWAT that out of your
hand not even a docu sign yeah no oh
what's that a
PDF I have a I have a theory of why it's
important now uh I saw an article the
other day I think it was Washington Post
or something like that it was somebody
legit kind of and they said that they H
did a poll where they said 1 of The V
said they would vote for uh whoever
Taylor Swift is endorsing
oh so they're idiots yeah yeah
definitely there and I don't know how
accurate that number is but I do know
that she has a huge influence on a lot
of people and the fact that the White
House came out immediately and said it's
like oh yeah protect our Golden Goose
like protect our our egg maker you know
whatever the phrase is golden goose egg
maker Golden Goose worked and then you
ruined it you just you went a little too
far egg maker okay all right egg maker
well I don't know she's her windows
about to close there's no male or female
there's just Eggers she also has a
compulsion by the way Taylor Swift this
woman has a compulsive Behavior to only
date aist Stars let's be clear yeah like
hold on you never found like a nice guy
who's just like a
lawyer yeah it took Travis Kelsey a
couple Super Bowl wins for yeah exactly
it's like oh wait you're in the biggest
franchise oh Twilight okay you oh wait
John Mayor okay you her and it's just
like come on hold on a second and then
she going to tell you about what matters
in life like she's like the perfect
little shallow Floy that she is all
right now let's go back to this is
something teenage girls been bullied
using AI generated images like for a
long time now to the point of suicide
here's a collage all references are
available like this is something that
has been going on it is a problem and I
do understand this to I want to be
compassionate to like a lot of people
say these kids have no problems you know
I I had to I was breathing an agent
orange you know in in N sure but you
also got to come home at some point and
being a young kid there is a chronic
pressure of abuse where bullying at
least you could kind of go home The
Bullying takes place wherever you go yep
and it's not lost on me that if you're a
young woman and other women are trying
to label you a that you go home and
boom now you have to deal with AI images
that's why girls end up committing
suicide so it is a problem and it's a
problem where legally maybe there is
something that can be done about it yeah
and a lot of people are asking the
question right now why are we just now
putting this conversation front and
center we've talked about a lot of cyber
bullying that's been something that's
been talked about but it's kind of this
nebulous thing that a lot of people
don't grab a hold of and understand what
it really means with this kind of
Technology out there it is created an
entirely new problem where it's not just
Taylor Swift it's some 14-year-old girl
that killed herself literally a
14-year-old girl killed herself I
believe last year because of AI
generated images making her out to be
this Floy like you can create these
images and put them out on the internet
you have I mean it takes seconds to be
able to do Terri and you've destroyed
somebody's reputation and you've
destroyed the world of somebody who's
not in a position to make great
decisions about life at 14 years old
especially girls with the pressure that
they have at that that age like I cannot
imagine having social media in high
school right now I can't imagine you cuz
I could go and take care of a bully I
can go and confront a bully right there
I can confront a rumor with my friends I
can't confront something that's already
reached thousands of people before I
even knew it existed yeah the other
schools in town and yeah exactly kids at
your church and no everything else yeah
it's terrible especially if you take
care of a bully who happens to be a
black guy you're the one on the hook
yeah it's okay though I got to pass but
you know what the good news is if you're
lgbtq AIP I don't think there's been a
single student bullied for that in the
last
[Music]
p
just so thrilled everyone's so
interested I really want to you know
start a movement a shower eating
movement I think for people who are
multitasking it's just going to be such
a huge relief in so many ways here's my
rules with shower eating a ledge is
really helpful something that you can
stick your cup off your yogurt container
your coffee your espresso whatever it is
you're enjoying but I like toon candy
turn it into a Crockpot of ass bacteria
wonderful your hair keep the soap that's
a big deal it's prettyy simple guys you
can do this come on Stephen that's not
weird at all I do it all the time what
you do yeah I do actually I gave I I
gave uh Tim a tape oh no
h
oh there there are many things troubling
about that you g you you gave that to
Tim willingly you d man you brought a
cameraman yeah yeah yeah Old
Pad oh well okay interpreter of mine
from they work at very cheap rates yeah
he's a good guy there's a lot about that
that is wrong but um now I understand
why everyone in the office is sick yeah
no one no one here would shoot it I was
it no I had to hire my own guy I don't
know I guess that's about all we really
have to talk about with the AI
pornography you can let me know what you
think or if you've been the victim of it
and uh if anyone by the way does it with
me just make sure you do the unit
Justice that's been a Hollywood
[Music]
minute
so I'm typing in right now Asian Steven
Crowder naked that's not doing a Jus not
oh that's really not fair I saw that
tape I'm a size 12 Triple E my friend
I'm not binding my
feet I think we we passed that the
threshold to start doing that yeah I
know well here's the thing this the
problem is it's reputational damage for
example Trevor Bower lost $100 million
contract with the uh with the uh the
Dodgers for something he didn't do won
the court case Johnny Depp won uh sorry
he he won eventually but he lost what
did he lose for Pires of the Caribbean
at least $40 million probably with the
Fran at least close to100
million until we find out that he was
the one who had a bottle thrown at his
head and someone took a in his bed
the guy is that a win did he win the
court case did Trevor bow have this
woman this hussy have to pay his legal
fees do they win he lost $100 million
contract it doesn't matter in other
words do you win if you win it if you
win the case yeah but if AI porn becomes
ubiquitous someone runs a search this is
what happens too it happened with comedy
clubs this is an issue where comedy
clubs used to be the wild west but if
you have someone who's too
controversial the booker just says I
don't want protesters I'm I'm just not
going to have them particularly in open
mics you would have clubs that do that
across the it's just not worth the
trouble even if they know that it's not
true even if you've been exonerated
that's the problem is not only do we
have a corrupt justice system in a lot
of ways but it's largely irrelevant if
you are in the public eye because they
can simply destroy your reputation and
they have more tools than ever you win
legally you lose yeah even if the facts
are on your side right right because it
takes time for that information to get
out there and will run with the LIE
before the truth ever catches up right
well the LIE pays up baby it does well
look at the look at the Donald Trump
case that just took this weekend that
just took place uh is it Jean Caroll
Carol $83 million think about this this
guy is being sued for defamation
effectively for in a colorful way saying
that he didn't Bang a woman that he
didn't bang he basically said I didn't
bang I didn't bang I would never bang
that like you can't say that it's
even though you didn't you can't use the
descriptors that's really what the
defamation is is he attacked someone for
falsely accusing him of sexually
assaulting her and they're saying well
yeah but you were too you were too
adamant you were to there was too much
Zeal in your attack against the lying
he must have been found guilty of
something in court right like having
rape with her you would have you don't
have rape some people you don't have
rape you take it or give it I'm
confused we should probably bring that
bring up he was $87 million he didn't
not for sleeping with her 83 sorry $83
million for insulting a woman who tried
to say that he slept with her for saying
she's ugly for saying she's ugly he said
it to the lady in the room is he going
to get sued by her too remember he
looked at her he goes just like you
you're not my type either you know that
kind I would never speak yeah exactly
that's what I said to her you know that
kind of was like what are you going to
say in other words if you say uh someone
says he slept with me no I didn't oh
yeah how can you Pro I can't prove it
but I would never sleep with her I would
never sleep with her
why because she
sucks she's gross she's ugly I would
imagine a horrible a worse than elisan
Omar leaves her brother with a smile on
his face
folks what are you going to say you have
to be nice to the person who tries to
Shake You Down this is a Banana Republic
in a lot of ways so just understand that
let's uh now talk about this because
this also brings us to hey mean words
versus actions that lead to Deaths
that's the story when we're talking
about these American soldiers who were
killed in Jordan who may have an
association with you know iran-backed uh
extremists so things are getting not
only out of control but we're
consistently on the verge of World War
III it's time for Gerald knows the
things
spare no expense you did spare no
expense I really appreciate that so uh a
lot of you heard this news that
yesterday right so 34 American soldiers
were injured three were killed in in
this attack in Jordan on Sunday Jordan
strike three US troops were killed and
at least two dozen more injured in a
drone attack on a small us Outpost in
Jordan near the border with Syria and
Iraq this is the first time US troops
have been killed by enemy fire in the
Middle East since the beginning of the
war in Gaza October 7th and and
obviously look when you hear that I mean
a lot of us were waiting for something
like this to happen because as soon as
you start putting troops in In Harm's
Way which there there obviously still a
lot of Truth In Harm's Way in the Middle
East but as soon as stuff started going
off in Israel and Gaza we knew like oh
man like that's just going to ratchet
things up in in in in in the Middle East
and and this is going to happen and it's
going to push us into a war the Biden
Administration quickly blamed a group
called the Islamic resistance in Iraq
and an Iran backed militia yes they
backed by Iran and they have a quote
over there yeah that's right he said uh
uh or I think this was released
officially from the White House thing
while we are still Gathering the facts
of this attack we know it was carried
out by radical iran-backed militant
groups operating in Syria and Iraq and
just to be clear you have these Iranian
proxies they've been they've been uh
attacking us Assets in the region for
for months yeah there's been over 150
attacks it's not like this is obviously
this one when when you kill some of our
soldiers and when you wound some of our
soldiers um that that is that takes it
to another level I get it but it's not
like they weren't trying in the the
other 150 attacks to do the exact same
thing they just have been less effective
and it's important to note that again
this is a guy from the administration
right we'll talk about the Iran deal
that took place with Barack Obama Donald
Trump very different
stance C can can you click the like
button if can we all acknowledge even
people whether you're a Democrat
watching or you're a Ron D santis guy
who hates Donald Trump as far as no new
Foreign Wars like the only president to
do it in our lifetime isn't that one
good thing and C there were far fewer
casualties of American soldiers like can
we all agree if there was if there's
only one good thing C can you give that
one to Donald Trump because this also by
the way was the result of a very harsh
on Iran policy so there's mean words
that you say this is going to pop things
off only nothing ever popped off and
then weakness weakness breeds evil
growing in strength Sunday evening I
think we have a clip Biden
mumbled that the US shall respond uh to
the strike I want to point out that we
had a tough day last night in the Middle
East we lost three grave souls and
attack one of our bases and I asked Sil
all three of us fall Jes we shall
respond God bless you all thank you for
allowing to be here and uh and wish that
to go to the bathroom is what he meant
to say I already went did I'm GNA do it
again hey guys do you hear that do you
hear that like resounding like American
soldiers will be unmolested the world
over and American citizens will not be
targeted did you hear that pounding of
the table the fist letting our enemies
know that they can't screwed around with
us did you hear that or did you hear a
weak old man yeah saying yeah we'll
we'll respond we'll get around to it a
weak old man with a pseudo mullet it's
not even a real mullet I don't know
who's advising him on the back of his
hair or if he's just never looked in the
mirror into the mirror in the barber
shop but this is what's really important
here is we need to look at the results
of the policies and exactly why we are
here with Iran and very likely we'll
make missteps going forward so long as
these people are at the tiller of the
ship let's compare Donald Trump
precisely versus former Vice President
Joe Biden with then and
[Music]
now uh so and by the way all references
are available at lth credit.com we put
the link in the description so let's
let's start with now actually in this
case we're doing it kind of in in
Reverse
Iran is more powerful than ever okay
let's go through a couple of quicke 2021
Biden lifted sanctions on Iranian
officials and petrochemical companies
right we talked about this with you in
September 2023 they unlocked 6 billion
dollars in oil revenue for Iran which I
don't really know why we unlocked I'm
kind I kind of thought hey we should be
locking up money should we throw away
the key like just forget where it or how
about this it's already locked yeah just
leave it oh you don't have to do
anything just take it you just just just
leave it and then you know but instead
we like we unlocked it and here you go
why you already have the money just keep
the money it's like parents with fat
kids you you have the key to the pantry
just don't open
it don't buy the cookies yeah don't let
them eat eat them yourself starve them
they'll lose weight and then you get to
then it comes to portion control so by
the way Iran uh said that uh they were
reassured by Qatar that it would have uh
that they would have access to funds
yeah because everybody was saying oh
well we we did unlock the funds but we
still control it don't you worry wor
don't you worry we still have control
over it like a where' the funds go yes
exactly sure I mean a a penny saved is a
penny given to terrorist organizations
who want to kill us so November 2023
then um sanctions were restored um and
there was waver it was a sanctions
waiver I should say they restored these
sanction waivers that opened up another
10 billion 10 more it's like six wasn't
enough $16
billion which I think probably goes a
long way in Iran
a little bit yeah yeah it's a couple
dishes it's like it wouldn't go that far
in New York City but you go out to you
know outer skirts of connty you can live
like a king on $16
billion so all these Kon trillionaires
what that is that's what it is yeah
exactly yeah it's Neo terrorist
re so all of these moves by the way they
were aimed to get Iran back in what the
nuclear deal that took place with Barack
Obama this is why this election is so
important you have eight years of Obama
really three years of Donald Trump
before the uh fabricated or the
orchestrated I should say pandemic to
destroy the last year of his presidency
so you're going to have eight three and
four and you're going to have a very
very clear contrast I just didn't know
that the contrast would be so Stark as
it relates to foreign policy who would
have thought that the Republican was the
one who stopped and never started a new
war now it was Donald Trump it Donald TR
all people the most Brash person out
there I I thought he would start a world
Conflict for sure well with all this
money all this all this money Iran
they're closer to nuclear capabilities
than ever can I just give you a really
quick note there leave that screen up
for just one second 60% is what they're
enriching the uranium to right now they
need about I don't know six to nine
months to be able to get enough for a
size of bomb that we dropped on
Hiroshima they're not at 90% which is
what they need to be yet you know what
peaceful is is used for what what you
have to enrich uranium for peaceful
levels 5% 5% right now they're 55 points
over the 5% there is no possible use for
this to be used peacefully this is them
absolutely 100% driving towards creating
a nuclear bomb and it's been going on
under a government's nose for a long
time and they haven't done a thing about
it no they haven't other than just
giving them money they giving them more
money to do it I don't understand do
they want them to drop a nuke so that we
can get into another war is that the
plan and by the way don't get it twisted
Hiroshima
Nagasaki bold move and I support it
we've done a whole segment on that I
just don't want people to get TST like
America is the only place to drop the
bomb yes do do it again sorry it
was very choice so ask we Haven again
have we have we what we haven't had to
do it again we haven't had we done told
you twice we absolutely did not have to
do it again and then MacArthur basically
kept the emperor up there he's like all
right we're going to keep the emperor
here because I think you're a God but
you're going to do everything that I
tell you to do did you know that with
General M know that oh yeah and then
there was a thing there was maybe
someone can pull this up there was
unfortunately where he what happened is
there was a picture of MacArthur next to
the emperor of Japan and he had only
been seen in remote areas uh where he
looked much taller the way they
photographed him and then he was next to
MacArthur and like oh my God our God is
really tiny and so uh they were saiding
we have to get rid of this to keep the
belief in the emperor MacArthur was like
you know what keep that one up
circulated like the first time I saw Tom
Cruz yes yeah yeah first time anyone saw
Tom Cruz all right so that is uh that
that's now but let's go back to then
okay the worst president right they'll
tell you in modern American history
let's look at what happened with Iran
okay first off Donald Trump responded
and it's very consistent to the attacks
on Sunday on Truth social saying this
this Brazen attack on the United States
is yet another horrific horrific tragic
consequence of Joe Biden's weakness and
surrender and then uh he's right uh
let's go back to his policies in May
2018 Donald Trump pulled out of the Iran
deal everyone said that that was going
to that was going to start World War III
he imposed very hard sanctions on Iran
we can look at the revenues the
differences between Donald Trump and
someone like former Vice President Joe
Biden crude oil revenues with Trump they
were 19.4 billion 20120 it went down to
7.9 billion as far as if you look on on
our dependence and what kind of money is
being sent to these countries despite
mean words Donald Trump said you cannot
have nuclear capabilities we are going
to ensure that that does not take place
but we also made sure that we weren't
playing nicely with them exactly
Independence was a huge component of
that it took away a big bargaining chip
from those guys and the the revenues
under Biden went right back up yep even
much higher so we used 2019 to get out
of Co years and Ed 20203 I believe or
2020 2022 42.6 billion versus 19 yeah I
know it's not even close here's another
thing another important example remember
in December uh 2018 the uh Iran backed
uh it was a kape hasah they killed this
American contractor and there were the
Iran backed militias they stormed us uh
I believe Baghdad United States Embassy
Bagdad you guys remember that okay what
happened the guy who didn't start a new
war president Trump responded by
assassinating Solan do you remember that
I like fricking he they yeah and the
media said this will start World War III
he was like great I love that he's dead
yeah I love that he's dead I hope it
hurt frankly he watched it on video I
believe died like a dog yeah di like a
dog a head up dog what do he say a
goodlooking dog or something I don't
remember that yeah you know s that
weakness thing from Trump is so true
because that Administration is so weak
on this they they try to act tough with
it when Kamal Harris like was on 60
minutes or whatever she was on she was
like my message to Iran is don't no just
don't and they did so what are you going
to do they're sitting around huddled by
it be like wait for it wait for it I
know what I got I
got can you believe this I know
but it's not just like I agree with you
one of you claim you're a mayor she'll
do a weird sex our our they're like it's
like they're they're speaking to a
toddler and it's the 17th time they said
if you do this there will be a
consequence and there's never a
consequence do you remember Barack
Obama's Red Line right they know what
this Administration will do they know
exactly because former Vice President
Joe Biden was there when they did
nothing the first time around well I got
to go do something I got I got to go use
a restro sorry guys I tried to hold
sorry okay all right we'll see you a
little bit later so look uh now you have
of course someone like uh you have
Lindsey Graham who's never met a war
that he didn't like um where he's
talking about hit a ram nowan now hit
him hard and the problem is when you
have rhetoric in the absent of act in
the absence of action it means nothing
and it actually puts you in a more
vulnerable position here's what we would
propose here at this program and you can
comment below reasonable Middle Ground
draw down uh troops in the region okay I
don't know why they're there we need to
reduce their vulnerability we should
strike Iranian proxies meaning going
after high value targets don't just go
don't Target soil in Iran you know it's
kind of like you look at the Art of War
don't just try and attack a village
because it doesn't really work to impose
heavy Financial sanctions or at least
not release money that we already have
in a box and allow Israel to use its
full force if you do all of those things
that'll at least get us closer because
that's what Donald Trump did yeah
it worked it's very clear with this
contrast and I know it feels like it's a
dry segment but it's this is something
you're going to have to watch it relates
directly to Israel and Gaza we talked
about these militia backed groups and
how so much of everything flows back to
Iran and right now they're testing
someone who they they know is not made
of the right stuff to deal with it can
we stop talking about Mean Tweets yeah
can we stop talking about words that
offend us hey do you feel safer today do
you think the world is more stable today
in 24 than it was when Donald Trump was
at the tiller of the ship in 2018 2019
2020 it's a genuine question and I don't
think that anybody can answer yes that's
been this week's then and
now I can't wait for Nikki Hy obviously
to come out and be like yeah we should
go in there and strike right now it's
like the warhawks are just coming out
like you have to respond but you have to
do it in a wise fashion right you can't
just go and start World War II well what
happens is when you've been weak and
you've been weak for such a long time so
this kind of attack happens now you got
to go okay I'm really Ser because you've
counted to three and nothing happened
exactly you got to go to the tool belt
because you have nothing else like we've
talked about with cops like you you've
got to go to the gun because we've got
nothing else we haven't done anything
else got to overreact now you know that
my dad when would count of three I don't
know if your father was this way he
didn't believe in the number one really
you know that yes because his request
was one was what he considered one so he
said all right I need you to go uh pick
that up there in the game room and I
wouldn't do it my dad would just say two
oh my God oh my God I got one second on
the
clock you're running as fast as you can
like the the timeline rewind on Amazon
Prime because it only has 10 seconds or
DeLorean that's true it's fair he would
just say two so the number two for years
I didn't like saying out loud it
actually like I I was like oh no two
that mean someone's about to get spanked
so
uh you can't you can't count to three
and nothing happens and I think your
request is one and two is that $6
billion vaporized gone you do it on
principle you don't even keep it for
yourself you burn it so they can watch
you're like oh no that really
sucks would you like to see what door
number three is yeah door number three
is hellfire hey how's Solan doing yeah
yeah just checking in oh yeah that's
right if I were a betting man I would
bet well not at the gates of hell he's
in hell hey by the way does anyone know
where Josh went he seems like he's been
gone for quite a while yeah he has
that's a
[Music]
long hey come on man there's other
people out here I got to take it two
he's got to it doesn't matter come on
just a minute got one slice
left come eat the pizza here I don't
know
[Music]
man no one out there in the Mission
Control eat the pizza nobody let let the
man finish I don't care if it's
breakfast pizza they do that now which
is also disting it's the way to start
your day wrong all right we're going to
continue and actually do a segment here
about the unhappiest states oh really
yeah uh exclusively uh on mug club and
believe we have some updates coming up
here soon regarding Black Rock you know
we've always talked about these big uh
stings and investigations it's not what
you know it's what you can prove Beyond
any shadow of a doubt and then you start
gaining more because because you know
more and then you're able to prove more
so
and everyone watching right now on
YouTube head on over to rumble because
if you're watching on Rumble you just
click this button you can join mugas $9
a month but none of this happens without
mug club uh YouTube piss
[Applause]
off
yeah